you
[Music]
all right good morning it is my great
pleasure to introduce today's speaker C
Liu Huang who came all the way from
Illinois and is absolutely not impressed
by what little snow we have here see Lou
is a recipient of the MSR PhD fellowship
and she has done a lot of work in in
different areas all of it interesting
today she's going to talk about
effective data versioning but she's also
done work while she was interning at
Microsoft Research on sampling with
probabilistic accuracy guarantees and
she's also done work in the context of
AI for selecting the best configuration
in which to train an ml model and more
things then then I'm even gonna mention
so she'll maybe briefly mention some of
it and if you're part of the loop feel
free to talk to her about that later all
right thank you very much and I'll hand
it over to Sela yeah thanks for the nice
introduction good morning everyone
I'm Sara Huang and I'm a fifth year PhD
student from UIUC
it's my great pleasure to be here and
share my thesis work on effective data
versioning for collaborative data
science so nowadays data science is
increasingly popular and has been
recognized as an emergent field so in
particular data science has lots of
applications in different areas like
finance healthcare manufacturing and
retail so how does data science
lifecycle look like typically data
science starts from task formulation and
then acquired data from say in lock
systems followed by data people data
preparation including like data clinging
transformation and then we can try to
understand and refine the data through
initial data exploration after gaining a
broad picture we can then further
investigate machine learning models and
in order to achieve a good machine
learning model the data data scientist
were typically try to incorporate more
new data and try different data
pre-processing as well as future
engineering operators also different
models after gaining a satisfactory
model we can then dip
and surveys and this will in return
generate more new data so we can see
this is an iterative process and during
this iterative process different
versions of the same data set will be
generated so during my PhD study I'm
working towards making data science
simpler and more efficient and spending
many of different stages inside this
data science life cycle like effective
data versioning and automatic data
extraction interactive data exploration
modeling and auto ml so I will not have
time to cover each of this topic in
detail but in this talk I will instead
focusing on effective data versioning so
as I mentioned the design T is the
routine we generate a number of
different versions by applying data
pre-processing and future engineering
operators and this is a real example
from biological domain where people are
collaboratively construct curate and
analyze on the protein-protein
interaction data set here protein 1 and
protein 2 forms a composite primary key
along with some numerical features to
indicate the interaction strengths of
different sources and initially we have
version 1 as Pera lodges to conduct more
lab experiments new record and columns
will be added and lead to a new version
v2 here simultaneously some experts can
work on their own working copy correct
and curate the data set and periodically
merge it back to the main line also data
scientist can download and analyze on
their own working copy so on and so
forth so we can see this is a nonlinear
process with branches and merges and
during this process hundreds to
thousands of versions are generated so
how are these versions managed in each
organization so here I will show how
data is managed in some computational
biology group at MIT so typically there
is around 20 to 30 students postdocs and
researchers and with around 100
by data shared welfare system and each
terabyte of data is costing around $800
per year for maintenance cost from some
local storage provider for unlimited
read and write access and this will
amount to around $100,000 per year which
is a large amount for an academic
research group so when some these
scientists want to do analysis then they
will first make a private copy and
modify and analyze it and also with ad
hoc names assigned it to each new
reproduced version like data set v1 here
however such ad hoc management is
problematic
just as shown in this comic never look
into someone else document folder
so these versions are simply lying
around the share file system and no one
really knows what it is what it contains
and how they relate to each other so
specifically from users perspective
there is no true collaboration there is
no easy way to merge somewhere else
modification and to share your new
reproduce the result also there is no
carrying capability to check the
dependency or perform some analytics
across different versions from the
system's perspective there is lots of
duty of are duplications among different
versions and which is a waste of storage
actually we are told that the team
members are periodically asked to clean
up the disk because of the disk and cost
constraint and also due to the lack of
metadata so there is no easy way to
figure out which versions can be deleted
and which versions are important so
there is a pressing need for system to
have managed this versions data set
there are me mainly three are desired
property for such a management system
the first is we want to have compact
storage to reduce the storage cost and
the second is we want to have efficient
versioning capability to enable true
collaboration and last but not least we
want to have data manipulation and
tics to have data scientist to reason
about across different versions so what
about some existing men are version
management systems the first thing that
comes to our mind may be the source code
version control system like it however
it is designed for source code and it
cannot scale to large data sets also it
only provides a limited data
manipulation and analytics functionality
while temporal database can only support
a linear chain of versions so the
question we ask here is can we make use
of the mature relational database and
support versioning for the relational
database so in this way we can inherit
much of the same benefits as relational
database for example the advanced query
capability the locking and the indexing
etc and meanwhile we can provide
versioning capability to it so the rest
of my talk is going to be divided into
two parts I'm going to tell you about
office DB which is a Botong approach for
structured data versioning specifically
I will force to show you a demo and then
our dive into some of the details in
developing office DB after that the
second part is going to be how office DB
makes certain restricted assumptions and
we try to relax some of the assumptions
to make it more general and these are
the two main parts of my talk after that
I will give you some brief introduction
to other works that I have been working
on during the course of my PhD and I
will conclude with some future works so
first I will introduce our build
prototype called office DB for
structured data versioning and this is a
joint work with another PhD student
Leakey and two master students and Aaron
from your Chicago and my advisor Aditya
so here is the overall architecture of
office DB office DB is a lightweight
layer on top of traditional relational
database and the user can interact with
off
to be using version control commands our
sequel like commands and then office DB
will try to translate the input
statement into sequel queries data that
can be executable in the underlying
database and the underlying database is
unmodified and it is unaware of the
concept of versioning so other version
logic is handled inside the intermediate
layer in which office dB so first let's
dive a bit into the query language
inside office DB first we can support
true collaboration WebKit style commands
so we allow checkout commit are much and
if also we can support advanced
acquiring capabilities to have a data
scientist to reason about different
versions so here I simply list some of
the useful queries that can be asked for
example the user can ask can we find the
version that is last committed by Alice
also can we retrieve the first bad
version that contains some Erin estoppel
and in the data science scenario maybe
we want to find the version that is with
the highest accuracy in some particular
data slice saying us and also maybe we
can find the history of a particular
topple so artists are the ones declaring
KPD capability enables the data
scientists to track versions compare
different versions and identify versions
satisfying certain properties so before
I dive into the detail I will first to
show a demo here
so on the left most part it is a file
visualizer where the user can view all
the files that are accessible to this
user and in the middle part is where the
user can type in the whole like commands
our version control commands and we will
return the results in the bottom part
while the rightmost part is a version
visualizer here each node is a version
and the edge Indian coast of Eurovision
between versions and in the bottom there
are some of the shortcuts when you click
the each button it will populate the
sequel of version control commands here
so I will first to show some sicko like
queries for example we can view the
content of a particular version and also
we can try to identify versions that has
certain property for example here what
we want to find instant diversions that
is with smaller than 100 protein pairs
which co-expression interaction larger
than 200 so basically we will commit
some in the button and we find version 3
and version 4 satisfy this property also
we can ensure any traditional sequel
queries on one version or a set of
different versions here we are issuing a
group I query at last next I will show
some of the version control commands so
we can first check out a version and
then we will see your some external
tools to process it or curate it so here
I will modify basically three different
records and curate them after modifying
it we can then save it and we can commit
this version back to the system so that
others can also visualize it or access
it
so we can see here there is a new
version pops up and we can try to
compare the difference between versions
and here we can see there are three
different tables and also we can try to
see the meta information of this
particular version okay so now we have
look at the demo so I would then dive
into some of the details in developing
office TV so there are two major
criteria when developing FSDB the first
one is we want to have compact storage
and the second one is we want to have
efficient versioning capability so we
want to in particular we are focusing on
two fundamental operators one is commit
and the other is checked out so in
overall we have three different
criterias one is storage consumption and
commit latency as well as checkout
latency these are the three criteria
when to kind our these are design
choices inside office TV so I will start
from a stronger approach here one knife
way is that we can augment each type
with a version ID vib here and then
however this has two major issues the
first one is the storage which can be
very large for example here the first
record is repeated twice so basically
each single record will be repeated as
many times as the number of versions it
presents in and the second issue is that
the checkout can be very costly because
we are wasting time in accessing
irrelevant records so for the first
issue I will come up with optimize the
representation scheme and for the second
issue we will propose a partition scheme
for it
let's start with the data representation
by the way if you have any question or
anything
it's not clear you can ask the question
yeah I think there are something wrong
with the slice hopefully it should be
fine yeah
so one natural way is that we can
combine the same tables and associates
each distinct apple with a version list
released here so even though array data
type is an anatomic data type it is
commonly supported in databases so in
this way we can reduce the storage cost
however the commit can be very costly
because if we clone version 3 as version
4 and we commit version 4 immediately
back to the system then we basically
need to access every single record that
presents in version 4 and append version
4 in each V list here so what about some
other alternatives so one other way is
we can separate the version information
from the data information because they
are independent to each other here we
have a table showing the data table with
an Augmented record ID and we need a
mechanism to encode the versioning
information from the version to the
records so one natural way is we can
organize it using record I are based on
record ID and the other way is that we
can organize it based on the version ID
so for the first one it also suffers
from costly commit because it is similar
to the combined table in the previous
slide but for the second one when you
want to commit a new version
you only need to insert one more typo
here with the version ID and is
associated record list so we eventually
choose the street by a list as our data
model and we conduct experiments and
verify that street by our list has the
best performance in terms of the storage
and the commit time
okay just just curiously right you you
would ultimately have a physical design
problem and so it not only depends on
how you're represent the data but also
which index structures you use can you
talk a little bit about that like what
what did you try out and what works and
what doesn't
ah so you mean different indexing
structure for them database system
underneath everything right so so you
can take advantage of whatever indexing
yeah so we basically for example for the
data table we have index on the record
ID and for the for this version cable we
also have index on the version ID and
this is to make a faster when we want to
do the joint between these two tables
and for other like indexing structures
we basically let users to figure out
like which index they want to build on
on top of the different tables you find
that most records are in most versions I
mean the like once the record has been
introduced I would imagine it's going to
be in pretty much every version from
that point on some some exceptions but
generally so it seems like you could
have a scheme this sort of says here's
the exceptions to that rule like here's
here's a list of what versions each
record is not in and then when you
commit it would just automatically be in
in every version did you guys look at
anything like that like making
assumptions about how oh we didn't make
assumptions on like the patterns of the
user in terms of different versions so
basically we are having like a list of
different versions this particular
records person seeing but maybe what
you're mentioning is like we can
condense this version list to like a
starting point and end point and then
maybe we can say oh it is this range but
maybe one particular version is not
inside this range we didn't consider the
compression of the V list here yeah
[Music]
or do you don't know yeah so in terms of
the schema change how we handle it is as
follows so for example there is a new
version committing with schema change if
it is only a deletion of some particular
column then we basically have a table
recording like each book what are the
attributes inside this version and if it
is a like addition of the columns then
maybe we need to change the schema so
there are two different cases the one
the first one is we can store it as an
additional table or separate table and
the other one is maybe we want to alter
the the original table so basically we
can use the auto command inside database
to make it to do the schema change yeah
there are two different options here
[Music]
so we basically support like get style
commands and we can support like Zuko
like a mouse yeah
okay so recall that okay
mr. intuition why is yeah so basically
we as we mentioned we have three
different criterias the first one is the
storage and the second one is commit
commit latency and the last one is the
checkout latency so in terms of when we
want to do this to the storage we have
mentioned like we can reduce the storage
by combining the same tables and then in
terms of the commit when you need to
commit a new version for the first one
you need to like a pent v4 to each of
the single records in the in the in the
upper part and you need to do an array
appending and for the second one you
when you want to commit a new version
you only need to insert one new record
and indicate in the version ID and the
artist so in this way you basically can
reduce the commit time at least of ID so
we are using the array data type inside
v3 and v4 have the same yeah so
basically I'm simply giving a very naive
example so for example is like you clone
abortion but actually you will do some
modifications by dimension modification
here sorry new ID so each record is
immutable and when you do some
modification then you will have a new
record ID yes so here I'm only showing a
naive example of cloning one version to
another version yeah but if you do some
modifications then it will lead to a new
ID and then I will append a new record
here in this data table
but it seems to me that what you're gain
in your commit improvement you would
lose on at least a certain type of query
profile if you're looking at a certain
already and you asked for the entire
version history your sprint idealist
would be kind of optimal for that query
but your split by others would be just
an expensive is coming in in some sense
yes that's that that's a good question
like also in the current implementation
we are basically considering like so
prioritize the commit and the checkout
operators and for other operators we are
not that care about it yeah it depends
on like the workloads okay so for this
one our record that we have like the
three criteria one is storage and one is
commit and also checkout time so in the
following I will tell you how we can
further optimize the checkout time by a
while partition scheme so as we
mentioned the checkout latency is very
large because we are wasting time in
accessing irrelevant records even with
index since the records are scattered
across the table so hundreds of
thousands of random access will
eventually be reduced to a foreskin so
for example here if we want to checkout
version 5 even if it only has three
records we are actually accessing the
entire table with seven records so how
can we eliminate accessing irrelevant
records so what we propose is we can
partition the big table into sub tables
so that we can reduce the checkout
latency but maybe at the cost of some
more storage consumption so we continue
the previous example we can partition
the big table into two sub tables the
partition one will contain other records
that is in version 3 and version 4 well
partition 2 will contain all the records
that is in version 1 2 & 5 and now when
we want to checkout version 5 we only
need to access the smaller table with
only four records
but as a trade-off we are repeating
broccoli twice in these two tables so we
can see there is a trade-off between the
storage cost and the checkout time so we
first define what is the storage cost
and what is the average checkout cost so
the storage cost is basically the total
number of records in our partitions
and at the checkout cost for each
version is the size of the partition
this version belongs to and the average
total cost is basically averaging across
our different food versions so here
comes the problem definition so given a
storage threshold gamma we want to find
a partitioning scheme such that the
storage consumption is weaving the gamma
budget and we can also minimize the
average checkout cost so we prove that
this is an np-hard problem by a
reduction from three partitioning
problem and in the following I will show
an approximation algorithm for this
so before we introduce our proposed
algorithm we first look at two extreme
cases and get some intuition behind this
algorithm so at one extreme case if we
store all the version inside one single
table then the storage cost will be
minimized because each distinct tapo
is appears exactly once and at an adding
stream if we set a store each version as
a separate table then we can see the
start every checkout cost is smallest
because we are not accessing any
irrelevant records when checking out the
version so if we visualize this too in
ignore plot where the x-axis is the
storage cost and y-axis is the average
checkol cost then they are basically
lying in two corners and what we want to
do is we want to find the optimal
partitioning scheme in between such that
the storage is within the budget gun and
the high-level intuition here is that we
can possibly group these devotions that
are similar to each other together right
such
that we don't need to we can only access
a smaller number of irrelevant records
when checking out the erosion and also
the storage cost is not increased it too
much sorry for the figure here so if we
use the traditional casting algorithm
then it will can be very time-consuming
because we need to in each iteration we
need to access the total number of
records and the number of records can be
as large as 1 billion so is that we
propose to operate on the version graph
so we can partition across the version
graph as shown in the demo the version
graph basically encodes the derivations
information and also indicates the
similarity among different versions for
example version one here has seven
records and version 2 has eight records
and they have six records in between so
in this way compared to working directly
on total number of records this is very
lightweight because the number of
versions is much smaller compared to the
number of records then how about the
effectiveness so as you may have already
noticed if we work on the version graph
here then it is actually exploring a
restricted staff space so for example
there is no way to partition diversions
in this way because other versions
inside the blue partition is not
connected without inclusion of version 3
in the yellow partition
however remarkably even with this
restricted search space we are able to
prove some approximation guarantee in
terms of the smallest storage cost and
the smallest checkout cost which is good
so we will show the algorithm you know
so it is very simple but it has very
strong guarantee so we first defined
that Co here they are coherent property
so mathematically what it means is that
the current checkout cost is weaving one
over there times the smallest possible
average checkout cost so the indication
is that the versions inside this
partition our is
to each other and our algorithm runs as
follows we start from the single
petition case where it has smallest
possible storage cost and then we were
forced to check whether it's satisfied
that they are coherent property so if it
is satisfied that they are coherent
property then we can stop because the
storage is the smallest and the current
checkout cost is not too far away from
the smallest possible checkout cost
otherwise we will spit we will split
this partition and so on and so forth so
we can prove that this has an
approximation guarantee in terms of the
smallest possible error checker cost and
the smallest possible storage cost as an
example so if the data is that has 0.25
and the math steps along the
partitioning process in 3 then we can
guarantee that the current storage cost
is weaving four times the smallest
possible storage restriction on the
search space so here's a simple example
say in each version I'm adding a record
indefinitely and this is all I do so I
create a chain of versions but every
every other version is identical to each
other so all the even versions of the
same and all the operation so the best
storage would be you know just two
versions so in that case I is it that
the coherent I mean is very restricted
search message that's only contiguous
versions for a molecule yeah so in that
case is basically in our cottage our
current partitioning mechanism we are
only having us constraint eight search
space so which means we can we are not
be able to partition the versions inside
like the odd partitions and the even
partitions in that case I guess our
algorithm will eventually be like
partition every so basically it will
have some cut points in between and then
group all the versions inside all in
the previous parts inside one particular
partition and then the others insert
another partition right so that so if
the dot coherent we were basically based
on like whether it is that whether it's
satisfied this mathematical equation so
in your case is I guess if it is only a
small train than it will be that
coherent but if it is a longer train
then it may not be the average will be
one minus all the other records so it
will be C average is going to be yeah so
in your case you can imagine in this way
right so basically if your group like
the even even even version with the art
version then basically the you can see
the partition is basically increased a
bit right because you are having like
the some of them are deleted and some of
them are added back so it basically the
partition will be the size of like say
like the the odd partition size the odd
version size and then when you check out
the version then if the number of odd
partitions are the number of word even
partition is very large then it can
possibly well it is this that coherent
property but you if you partition them
in like to like turn ten versions inside
one group then you satisfy this coherent
property yeah then we can guarantee like
the the the storage cost and the average
check out cost so we can further
illustrate this using an example here so
basically initially we will store other
versions
inside one partition and then we will
check whether it has dealt coherence so
for this one it is not just coherent
then we will snip the edge that is with
the smallest weight and we can then
result in two partitions and we again
check whether it is their coherent or
not so if it is not then we will again
snipped
edge and then result into three
different partitions so now each
partition satisfied that the article
here and property then we can terminate
so we further considered this algorithm
with compare this algorithm with two
existing custom based algorithm one is a
cooperative and one is k-means with some
versioning benchmark from previous paper
and we first look at the effectiveness
where the x axis is the storage size and
the y axis is the checkout time so as an
example the store this point shows the
storage size is around zero two point
three gigabytes and the checkout time is
around two point nine seconds and we can
see as the increase of the storage size
basically we can reduce the checkout
time and also our proposed algorithm
last page is dominating the other two
algorithms and of the other two
algorithm actually k-means is performing
better and it is quite close to last bit
so next in terms of the efficiency so on
average we can we observe three orders
of magnitude speed-up compared to two
clustering based algorithm and if you
still recall that k-means has very a
good effectiveness property but here you
can sometimes not be able to finish the
algorithm as shown in this cutoff here
at last we will show the benefits of
partitioning so again the x axis is
three different data sets and the red
one is the one without partitioning and
the other two are with a storage budget
so we can see as we increase the storage
twice from four gigabyte to eight
gigabytes we can actually reduce the
checkout time dramatically any question
for the office to be part
and his face you have also done
experiments on the query processing
reading on how much work it does so if
you for example um basically we are
optimizing for the like checkout time
and the commute time so if for example
in the case you mentioned like I want to
have more work load on the recent
version then it is basically saying we
will have a work load on the checkout
time on the checkout cost so our
algorithm can be generalized to the so
yeah I understand that so a weiming is
like if you have a workload of different
queries on different versions then you
can possibly basically say I have to
book load on different versions and then
in that case you were basically
materialized that the latest version and
set store it as a separate table and
then in that case when you issue a query
then you can post your performance so it
seems like you're you're you're geared
towards the worst case data version if
you if you actually use it I mean you
might you might see something like you
know concentration of records that keep
getting changed that maybe a new record
is more likely to change soon but an
older records probably not changing that
often if you if you invite those things
or you assume that some of the depth of
each interval change is going to be
small is there something else that will
actually be better or are F
I mean I'm like in videos and stuff
right you have iframes and you have the
Lord of nebulae frames and then you take
care of the right frame put things like
that ticket in this context or like when
you applied this to real data sets yeah
you see em did you see any such such
patterns I think one possible way is
basically saying like um instead of so
you so basically you can have a chunks
structure and inside this Chungcheong
structure you maybe want to group the
ragout the similar records are together
and then you do the optimization but in
this one we didn't consider the take the
patterns into consideration imagine how
you're not using the database any longer
as with its built-in indexes and
capabilities of capturing or locating
records so isn't it kind of why don't
you use like a first-class temporal kind
of merchant in a base for version index
like an interval index or something
right which might make it easier to to
query processing on the data so whatever
so for the first thing is compared to
temporal database it is the version
graph it's a tag so it is not easy to
encode them like into a range right so
that that is the first thing and the
second thing is for the list of versions
so array data type is support so we are
building our system on top of Postgres
and a rate data type is supported in
Postgres
and it is true that array for for the
array data type it is not having a very
good optimization
yeah and we are currently exploring some
of the direction of how to rewrite the
query in terms of the arrays so that the
query process the query execution can be
faster for example one knife way is you
can uh nested arrays and then
do the joins and another way is for
example inside post quest they are
having joins like you can have one
record ID and you can try to do a binary
search in the ArrayList yeah so there
are different mechanisms to handle the
array optimizations and we are currently
still exploring how to rewrite the
queries so that we can optimize yeah
yeah we didn't consider the the
provenance systems yet but I guess and
especially for this one actually you can
see it is not much of the provenance so
it's basically you have checked the
version graph and then for the records
that has primary key and you can
possibly check the drainage after this
particular record but in addition to
that we are only a maintaining like the
some metadata of these particular
versions so I guess it's not very much
of really provenance information which
is fine so you have a best friend its
command is going to generating in your
person that's the core screen
information yeah from via review from
being good I want to be allies to the
output and this is trans generate these
are degrees as you're creating the RIT
to be released is going to go forward
provenance and
hi team this is I guess it's because of
the design of our system so we are
allowing the external tools to process
the data so we are actually not be able
to check the operations that is done
inside one particular version yeah so if
we can capture like the different
operators and how the records are
evolving then maybe we can use the
provenance systems in this one's for
example as I shown in the tablet we are
using are letting the users to use some
like external tools to handle it so we
are not being able to capture all the
provenance informations is a good
direction as I was mentioning in the
later if we can capture all the code and
the workload and also the
mmm-hmm Christmas so at the beginning
you talked about this file the biology
lab and they have these versions of the
data mm-hmm and you've you've really
tune your system for assuming that
people are kind of making changes at a
data to like adding tuples are moving
through holes manipulating tuples but
some of the examples you gave on that
first slide where like you know
underscore normalization which I assume
maybe they've normalized some whole
column or something so if some if
someone normalizes a column it's gonna
create a it's going to double the
database right it's gonna add a whole
new set of tuples that's a good question
so it depends on how we do the data set
difference so actually if for the
normalization case you can consider it
as you are adding a new column right so
you are having two different columns and
then you basically are doing the schema
change now okay if someone wanted to add
a column double the size of everything
now you have to pulls with or without
caught the columns or can you mark that
column as being there for some tuples
and not for others
yeah so basically as I'm the by row just
asked so in order to handle the schema
change thing if it is a newly added
column then basically we were first we
will have a table that is recording all
the attributes that is inside this
particular version and then if there is
a new column added we can do two
different things the first thing is you
can try to choose to create a separate
table and the other thing is you can try
to utter this original table and then
you basically use the database commands
like order add a column yeah to do those
key to handle the schema change if I
have one just one entry and now I add a
column would that become two entries one
one the original entry and then one with
the value in the new column and each one
is version dinner version table
do you have a way of having one entry
line conversion table says one version
has this column in the other version
doesn't yes yes so you will have one
entry and then you will have to the
table recording which attribute is
inside yes yes just for simplicity I
only show like the records before schema
change you can refer to the paper yeah
we talked about it yeah okay then I will
go to the second part so we mentioned
that obviously we make several
restricted assumptions and here we want
to relax some of the assumptions to make
it more general so first I have work on
changing the storage data into the
storage representation from the
structure data to a more general data
formats and we try to allow a more
general traversal language that is
beyond vehicle beyond psycho and I also
worked on a setting where the user is
not starting from scratch instead they
want to boostrap the process that has
already been done so in this talk I will
simply focus on the generalized the
storage engine generalized storage
representation so this is a joint work
with are so mixed Amit and more from
your maryland's and as well as my
advisor Aditya so different as we
mentioned different from office TB here
we want to deal with different data
formats ranging from structured and
structured to unstructured data and one
common thing with office TB is that we
need to balance between the storage and
the checkout cost so one knife one
natural question is can we just use the
mechanism inside office TV right so the
problem here is that we don't know what
is each individual record if we are
handling an unstructured data set and
all we have access to is some black box
tipping mechanism that can give us
they are between versions so this is the
assumption we are starting with and this
assumption is general are powerful
enough to handle different data formats
therefore we are using a data based
approach what it means is we can either
store it sent some version in its
entirety or materialize it and for some
other version we can store it as the
modification from an existing version so
what is there here that can be in
different data form are different
formats for example we can represent
using your next difference or we can
represent it in using sequel script
often some particular data type we can
even use axel next we will show how we
can represent different versions using
this data based approach so for example
we can there are three versions here and
we can materialize version 1 and start
the other two versions in a linear train
as the modification from its previous
version and in this way the storage cost
is basically 100 plus 30 plus 10 so 30
here means that they are between the
version 1 and version 2 and when we want
to check out a particular version for
example if we want to check out version
1 because it is materialized
so the checkout cost will simply be 100
megabytes and for the second version and
the third version we basically need to
start from the materialized to version
and then trace all the way down to this
particular version talk about the access
cost you only care about the amount of
storage that you have to read you don't
it's a good question for simplicity I
only show like the case where the
storage cost is the same as the equation
cost but actually the storage cost can
be different from the equation cost and
we have that in the paper I didn't show
it here and alternatively we can
materialize like the version 1
and then start the other two versions as
the modification from version one and we
can calculate the storage cost as well
as the total recreation cost accordingly
also we can materialize version 2
instead of materialized version 1 and
then start the other two versions as the
modification from version 2 so in this
way we can have a smaller storage cost
and also a smaller total check-out cost
so we can see there are two criterias
here one is storage cost and one is
check-out cost and in the following I
will simply focus on the case where we
have the constraint on the storage size
and we want to minimize the average
total cost so this is the same as that
in office TV and next I would show some
of our proposed algorithms so we first
map this problem definition into a graph
setting so here we have four versions
and the third here basically means than
the edge here basically means that they
are between versions and we will first
we were first introduced a novel version
here and we will connect this now
version with our other versions and here
25 basically means when the version 1 is
materialized
what is the storage cost ok and let's
look at one possible storage graph
representation so in this one what we
are saying is we are basically
materialized version 1 and version 2 and
we are storing version 3 as the
modification from version 1 and storing
version 4 as modification of version 2
ok so we can see the total storage
cluster is basically the summation of
all the edge edge weights inside this
graph right and the checkout cost for
example if we want to recreate version 3
we basically need to start from this now
version and walk along the path from
this now version to the version 3 also
we can observe that this is a tree the
storage graph must be a tree because in
order to
we create one version we only need one
pass from the NA version to this
particular version okay so with this up
observations we can then dive into some
of the problems so the first one is if
we only care about the storage size and
there is no constraint on the recreation
cost then this can basically be
transformed are reduced to a minimum
cost a blessin's problem because the
storage size is basically the to add the
weight Sun inside this tree and on the
other hand if we want to minimize the
recreation cost and there is no
constraint on the storage cost then this
is actually a shortest path tree problem
because the checkout cost for one for
one version is basically the path
weights from the now version to this
particular version so what we want to do
is we want to balance between these two
three so we want to find the spanning
tree that is in between of the minimum
cost addresses and the shortest path
tree so we proposed a local with the
local mall greedy algorithm well we
start from the minimum cost addresses
which has the small smallest storage
cost and then we intuitively add more
address orders in each iteration we are
picking the edge that has the largest
ratio between the reduction in the
recreation cost and the increase in the
storage cost so let's look at one
example here so this is a spanning tree
in the intermediate layer into in the
intermediate process and basically what
it means is we are materialized version
1 and version 2 and we are store or
other versions as the modification from
version 1 and version 2 and we can
calculate the ratio for each dotted line
and then we can find the
the edge between now abortion and
version four has the largest ratio so we
will pick this edge and remove the edge
from version one to version 4 what it
essentially means is that instead of
storing version 4 as the dart from
version 1
we are materializing version 4 instead
so we compare this algorithm with some
modifiers and other heuristics one is
modifying prints algorithm prints
algorithm here is basically the famous
algorithm to calculate the minimum
spanning tree and the second one is from
delay constraint scheduling literature
and the third one is I get repair
heuristic so again the x-axis is the
storage cost and the y-axis is the total
recreation cost so we can see as the
increase of the storage cost we are
reducing the recreation cost with the
reducing the star recreation cost and
these are - these tool dotted lines are
the smallest possible recreation cost
and the smallest possible storage cost
we can see with a small increase on the
storage budget we can actually reduce
the recreation cost dramatically so in
addition to this problem definition we
also consider different cases where in
the story the optimization go and the
constraint and also as Christian
mentioned we consider the case where the
dirt is basically the storage and thigh
is basically the check out the
recreation cost we consider different
cases here
to restrict the martial-arts the craft
as all these formulations yes
so basically the question is whether the
the storage graph should be a tree so
dark he says you may imagine that we
don't want to be a tree that is much so
if you merge two versions into one
version then you may want to have an
attack instead of a tree but yes in this
problem definition we are constrained to
start by ocean as the modification of
only one portion instead of multiple
versions so you can think of in this way
if if it is not much then a tree must be
the bad the optimal solution right
because because you can you can think of
in this way if if you can retrieve the
highest so first in terms of the storage
cost right if you delete one edge then
the storage cost must be reduced right
and the second thing is is if you're in
terms of the recreation cost if you can
retrieve a smaller recreation cost for
this particular version using one edge
in stuff instead of the other one then
Masek aliyou can remove the other edge
right because there is no no need to add
this particular this other edge
yeah it will not be used because it is
are like a shortest path problem yes so
it is a sub optimal so if if this
version has the the optimal recreation
cost then it's like a descendant must be
having a optimal cost for this
particular version yeah so as I
mentioned the only violation is that if
you consider much instead of starting in
which motion as the modification from
one particular version then tree must be
the optimal structure yeah for all the
definitions yes let's see we'll finish
hold your questions till the end and
whatever time we have at the end we'll
use for questions sorry but I want to
make sure you can finish your talk thank
you
so we have talked about the office TB
and also the generalized storage
representation
so the overall takeaway here is that
with only a lightweight layer on top of
traditional database we can enable
effective data versioning and we can
enable data scientists to reason across
different versions and the second
takeaway is that with very simple but
very efficient algorithm we can optimize
the performance a lot so in chewing in
the post office DB and the generalized
storage representation pad we witnessed
that observe that with smaller increase
in the storage we can reduce the
checkout time dramatically and the third
thing is for different settings we may
require different algorithm for it for
example for office TB we are using
record level deduplication but for the
generalized storage representation we
are using a data based approach so in
the following I will briefly talk about
some of the other works that I have been
done during the course of my PhD study
so I'm also involved in lots of the
interactive data exploration project
so well we want to find fast response
time for each different queries so in
particular we started to I started two
different videos
sorry video queries which are two parts
which are part of the language project
inside our group for the first one we
want to fast identifying the future
pairs that can explain the separate
baby-g given two different sets and the
second one is given a histogram we want
to find the match to his Qin in a fast
manner and in addition to the video
carrier I also work on aggregate
aggregate queries during my internship
here in the imax group in addition i
also worked on like autumn autumn
automatic data extraction from locks
well we want to find patterns inside the
lock data set and try to extract the
structured format from the unstructured
locks as well as the autumn
machine-learning for large-scale
large-scale data set well we basically
draw the intrusion from
approximate query processing and applied
here into the auto ml the last one is
from my internship in google well we
want to do the table
synthesis and table compression and well
we try to apply deep learning techniques
to do the attribute ranking at last I
will show conclude with some of the
future works there can be potentially
done so but the first thing is in
addition to that they have versioning we
are also having the model versioning
during the iterative process and can we
build some tools to have data scientists
to inspect the model and check how model
evolves in an efficient manner such that
for example the users can ask queries
like what is the data slice this
particular that this model performs
worst and
so like what is the why this model
degrade when the time evolves so the
goal here is that we want to fast
forward the result to two different
queries instead of letting the users to
do to examine it in a brute force way
also in addition to the data versioning
we may want to build a management system
that is an end-to-end data science
lifecycle so we want to include not only
the data but also the code as well as
different models such that we can
capture our different informations or as
you mentioned like different provenance
informations and so that the data
scientists can better reason about the
workflow and the data and the model more
broadly I'm also interested in
developing tools to make data science
simpler and more efficient in different
stages of the whole lifecycle right
that's pretty good thank you
[Applause]
is that you grow all the crap you start
from so if the third have already know
more than so so there must be you're
trying going quality like if you
materialize this version then it will be
the smallest cost and if you're starting
with some other existing version and
then use the data to basically check
trace the path from the materialized
devotion to this particular version then
the cost must be bigger than the cost
when materialized this potion what do
you mean by a number of different
versions that there is a constraint of
the storage cluster so because of the
constraint of storage cost you may not
be able to materialize all the versions
so you can only like started out instead
of materialized these particular
versions so basically inside this
problem there are two parts the first
part is which versions should be
materialized and then for the others
that is not materialized which death
should I store so which versions should
I store the data own right so that's how
the two major problems inside this
problem
actually abortion law can't be portion
to classic they do assume you can
actually have an older version that is
true all based on our newer version the
older version that is 10 that will
result in a new version so basically you
have a old version and you have a new
version and then if this old version is
evolves evolves things will result in a
new abortion which the process when
you're creating new versions because it
seems like you during the process of new
it in new version after version you
actually have a limited choice of how to
like mature as this new version right so
it's not like you have the full freedom
to actually compute a new yeah so
basically the question is is a repack
problem on online maintenance problem
right so in for example in the previous
part we are considering the online
maintenance and then we can do the
repair periodically so basically you can
as you mentioned you only have worry
restricted choices and then you can use
a sub optimal solution and then
basically you can try to repack it
periodically see same for this one so
you can first make a decision of like
storing it in as a modification or you
can so basically if you look at the
alby's and it is also like so you can
think of it as an intermediate step and
then you can do yeah yeah and then we
organized this this distri into a more
of optimized one
if this is the case you don't like but
the ogre can also consider the cost of
the migration for bond yes yes yes so to
do these algorithms do you use the
deltas between all pairs of versions
I'm already computed for you yeah that's
also a good question
so in currently in our experiments we
are basically calculated like within
penthouse instead of other data matrix
but it's basically depends on like how
how good you want you want it to be so
there is a trade-off like calculating
the dots between among different
versions so you know experiment we
constrained it into like 10 hops that
calculation you materialize every
version and compute all the deltas to
all those materialized versions or do
when you check it in you you compute all
the deltas at that moment answer I guess
yeah so so basically you can you can
choose to like calculate in during after
you commit it yeah so first because you
when you commit it you may want to like
do it in a very fast phase so basically
you can try to compute a Delta between
this version with one particular version
and then commit it immediately and then
after the commit process you can do
repack and then you can try to compute
mods and then try to do the repair
computer Delta from to Dalek you have
two deltas and obviously you go just
counting the deltas but is there any
assumption that you could or any
advantage if you could just compute a
new Delta based on these two Delta's
that might be smaller than so there is
like as I mentioned there is triangle
inequality right among like the
distributions but there is not like you
cannot ask me exactly what tested this
date will be there's no to say here's
two sequential Delta's give me a new
Delta it would actually
materialize it and recompute the Dalton
yes yes then when you say compare or
psdb something stupid in a business
ticket
what did I get why would I use it and
then going for it for better storage
later checkout time I mean what's the
what's the higher order story so for
office to be the highest storage is like
as the starting point I can show you the
interview with a mighty group in Fargo
just maybe I'll just remove you faster
so the starting point is is to is this
one so the starting point is basically
when we talk to some some of the
computational biology groups and they
are saying that they are wasting lots of
time lots of money in the storage so the
first thing that is as I mentioned like
you can have a compact storage right the
second thing is you can so as I
mentioned like the the you can set a
budget for the storage consumption you
can set the budget to like two times
thousand of the smallest possible
storage yeah so it depends on like how
you set the budget and then the second
thing is because of you have lots of
meta information metadata record it and
you know like the version graph so
basically when some when you want to do
some analysis you can based on the the
information that is maintained inside
this system and the other thing is for
example you want to do analysis across
different portions for example in the
data science scenario you may want to
see what is the version that has the
highest accuracy on some particular data
slice like in the US and then you can
easily issue like sicko like queries to
answer this this ones so basically you
can think of it is like enables the
versioning capability and also you can
do the advanced of having capable
analytics across different versions and
track versions and also identify potion
that is satisfying some certain property
yeah and I mean while you will have a
very compact storage
for instance in this data set but you
mentioned it it's a hundred thousand per
year to curate this data set so like
what would work he has reduced it you we
didn't a particular down the experiment
on this one but it basically depends on
like how many versions hold and how they
are similar to each other so for example
here for example twenty to thirty
students and each time when they do some
analysis they make a private copy then
obviously this one can be reduced so yes
it also used like the other based
approach and for example in this one we
only consider one hundred versions and
this is a Linux folk data set and we can
see the git will take around two one
hundred megabytes and why are ours in
just in terms of the storage cost not in
terms of the equation cost we can see
like an hour one is like around 160
megabyte so basically we lad biologic
teams in our university to try it so
some of them find like the ones to query
capabilities very useful and while some
like they don't want to use the system
or they are reluctant to use the system
because they need to basically change
their behavior so they need to like
every time when they generate a new
version they need to commit and check
out the version and another thing is as
I mentioned we only care about like the
data set portioning so it's not like an
overflow of the post data and code and
and the models so they feel it is very
restricted so it cannot capture
automatic information unless the user
can
like manually typing the them the matter
information into the system they don't
want to like manually typing automatic
information they want to have an
automatic way to help them capture all
different informations yeah and also we
get contacted by some I think the
genereal research from Virginia and they
want what they want to do is they want
to do the neuroscience and annotation so
they basically first use deep learning
to annotate the the feet of figures and
then they will need to do human
proofreading of each problematic area
and they said it will be very useful for
them to consider different versions and
support of advanced acquiring
capabilities yeah so let's pretend that
this was in production some kind of
enterprise environment that was holding
PII and someone issued a GPR request
that required backing out some
information from home so imagine that
the way out what would probably buy you
know swapping out beautiful versions of
Records with you know the fact that
information got masked would there still
be capability to recognize that between
versions one is version 2 of some
particular record that a particular
field had been challenged even though
with actual values and those fields
might mint along the president in story
or I mean how do you how do you envision
supporting something like the GPR
request for a system like this um so I'm
what not worry familiar with the gdpr
request so like it depending on where
data is stored there's a law in tabular
a lot of large organizations have
adopted that requires that anyone
holding on to like personal data has the
capability to back out that data if the
people who are subjected to it requested
so if so if someone wanted to have their
data cleared out of all versions you
know some record how imagine that
something that's not supporting helping
you imagine like it's how that happens
like this is the support I see so
basically if we want to flash your
particular grant prospect then basically
I guess you can simply find those bear
claws and then try to remove those bear
claws and then accordingly you can
update the versioning information from
the ocean table
do you also compare with offline
optimists in your paper boy it was too
expensive to compute the offline of
tables people using we to compare I
didn't show it here but in the paper we
do consider like the integers we
formulate this as integer linear
programming problem and then we compare
the greedy a with an with the linear
integer programming method but that one
is basically we are using some software
and it cannot so if you have we did a
machine to conduct the experiments on
like constrainted and I bought hops into
5 so in our experiment we placed at it
as 10
yes I if the number of Delta is smaller
than obviously it will affect the
algorithm yeah because you will have
like less search space our cost means
such days we feel information is enough
to give you same result there is the
incremental approach possible that you
start with enough information
and yeah awesome if you use make use of
the trampoline quality as are profound
for you see our boundaries so I think oh
we imagine for collaborative effort
Tennessee tomorrow actually very social
functionality but over the course of a
chopper you didn't talk about margin
also is that it's a dying your paper or
if you haven't come to merge it yeah we
we do anything for mechanical for motors
so currently what we are doing it is
basically we chased this version back to
its common ancestor of these two
versions and then we figure out whether
there is a conflict in in terms of each
record if there is a conflict then we
basically use them so when you merge two
versions you will have like specified v1
and v2 and then we if we inspect there
is a conflict we've simply used v2 - all
right the the record inside v1 so that
is our first report to the user that
there is a conflict if they want to do
like much still want to do the merge
then we will simply overwrite it yes but
we have some ongoing work on how to do
the conflict resolution inside this
space yes yes right yes exactly
all right don't work no more take
instead let's thanks equal again
[Applause]